so on in the text I'm still fighting
here in masses I've
played quite ethically
and also quite undemandingly
how many permanent c4 do
you want to assert yourself here how
will you probably manage to do it
3 strange move
well good way
yes ii 4 0 to go through
and  again a little bit against places
yes what you don't really like how to
continue playing now
jumper how much I don't want to put in anymore
I don't need it anymore but it could
get weak do
n't just wait normally
then I came up with a knock that
no one here
So how about now take it here
and take runner II 4 of
the vff 2 is not exactly the hero
good runner club competitions namely
maybe do b5 goodness well
then I'll just take the field
forever
just see that the position can't
open up can
also do it  should should be black
when the moment is ripe for it,
well your fifth case isn't
bad,
that here today's 66 ul
was better, well
that gives you an idea, like my god, it
's nonsense, that's
nonsense, why didn't I prevent that,
well  I would have really prevented it better
now you have to see that you press here what has it was, you
just have to prevent c4 then
that's a winning position for black
and it's very easy to do so you do
n't have to do anything big anymore
that practically wins itself
the eternal jumper
and now you're in this nonsense in here
unbelievable why doesn't he run 5
now everything is running like clockwork again
I think only springer
5.42
no one exists he doesn't do it with
small children but I don't know
why why
not
why  We supposedly didn't work,
yes, it was also and and
Springer here is threatening, he
also has a pawn increase
on top of that,
Tomi Rheins can really take it, he
has nothing on line
21, only seven
at that time, but well,
yes
and still a bit unpleasant,
yes  There's no threat whatsoever but
I'm still tied up in a strange way.
I'd like to lift the bondage.
Right answer of the
participants.
No one then complies easily. Yes,
that's going to be really dangerous,
apart from the fact that I should have
prevented
it  Almost yes, I got myself into
trouble from what was
actually a great position